I did a three-week expedition to the
Auckland islands which is in the
sub-antarctic and it was in wintertime
the only time that these whales are
there so on this one day is gigantic
whale 45 feet in length as big as a city
bus just swam down and gently approached
us on the bottom my assistant who's a
great diver just kind of posed perfectly
standing on the bottom and was dwarfed
by this massive animal I think our
hearts were beating out of our chest
because it was just so exhilarating but
there was no threat by this animal it
just had a great deal of curiosity about
us in a situation like this you're in
the bottom of the ocean alone and you've
got this thing that looks like a
submarine swimming up to you but it's
looking at you and it's thinking and you
see its tail moving and your heart is
pounding your brain is just racing my
brain is racing thinking don't screw up
get the picture
you know nobody's going to believe this
I've had some magnificent animal
encounters out there in the wild but I
have to say this one tops the list